oh let me give a shout-out appreciate
that six five four three two one zero
okay I'm not sure if I'll play a gambit
every game will see opponent offline
opponent online
[Music]
can we see a couple of variations on the
Scandinavian oh my point is Ertz without
really giving me time to berserk back
yeah so I'm playing a scandi playing ooh
Oh
Icelandic variation is e six right
this is Icelandic variation shout out to
tog II who's probably not here oh if I
take back then we we go into some French
exchange I'll play Bishop before first
just accelerating development and then
I'll take I'm not scared of queenie 4
because knight c6 it's actually a kind
of nice position because i all Castle
first and I'll get a rook to Yeats to
exploit White's King my Castle right
away actually no I'll take first the
double hammer saw McLovin hammer I'll
have so many hammers hammers everywhere
okay so Queen a4 only attacks my king
Bishop defended first move that comes to
mind is this would have to expect Queen
b3 and then maybe Queen e7
I think there should be seven queen bee
three Queen e7y has to defend somehow
probably Bishop e2 and then like Bishop
Bishop c6 I kind of like that the other
option is knight c6 which also looks
very appealing because knight c6 I'm
attacking this still Bishop d2 expected
and then castling actually looks nicer
because in this line I get to Castle
sooner and when I Castle I'll have the
double threat of rook e8 and Knight
takes d4 this looks very nice and yeah
if trees all take first on d2 and white
will lose casting rights
okay so White's desperately wanting to
castle calculating this maybe queen e7
at some points this is a classic example
of one side being just a little bit too
slow to castle but I still have to play
this correctly that's Queen e7
so there's interesting idea here for
white queen e7 I think like could castle
cousin if I take and then Winnie -
there's rookie AE one and then I'm kind
of in trouble
so maybe Bishop g4 just completing
development and now yeah why can't Qasim
now because then I take and take okay in
this line I can take on d2 first this is
very nice
anyone know which software mr. Rosen
uses for streaming stream labs OBS it's
a nice software and it's free it's
pretty user friendly this is what it
looks like
infinity whoo it's actually infinity
okay yeah going back to the game Oh
Bishop c4 legal move in Queen f5
I mean white suffering with a king I'm
d2 just really no shelter ideas of Queen
f4 I mean there's so many ideas here can
bring the other rook in
calculating queena for cuz where does a
king move you can see three kings see
three rookie three it's a little bit too
crazy though maybe it just takes on f3
in that line yeah King c3 takes on half
three this will be nice yeah all this
puzzle rush has prepared me for her
greatness so there's only one thing I
have to watch out for is after it takes
white threatening to oh why it's not
even threatening that cuz I can take
back I just have to be careful of Queen
alignments so I could take on c6 Queenie
fives a move Queen f6 is a move Queen f6
just curious where the King will go it
goes back I I don't have Ricky to goes
to be 300 the position let's take with
the bishop and then a5 a5 a4
I mean b5 also looking nice
maybe b5 first if takes takes takes rook
b8 I mean yeah it's just too much fun
with the King on b3 tough game
[Music]
yeah the Icelandic it was like Icelandic
but kind of declines but it worked out
nicely white was just a little bit slow
I think we need for is just a clear
mistake doctor tournament's second place
I don't want to play the whole thing but
I might get sucked in because I'll be
fighting for first place I guess we'll
see yeah I miss my chance to berserk but
no I'm being more instructive this
stream I'm not deserting I can't give in
to peer pressure or chat pressure
yeah it's not too often though or my
opponents berserks and I know Boozer
usually it's just a result of missing
things don't bezerk or play fun
entertaining lines okay I mean okay I'll
still try and be entertaining but
instructive mistakes priority what what
opening do people want for whites tell
me within the next ten seconds what
opening someone anyone Kings gambit
efore wow so many kangs gambits vienna
we have a caro-kann okay I'll play what
I what I enjoy playing against Carol
cotton is a to Knights attack and
[Music]
opponent offline I feel so lonely also
good luck to my opponents claim victory
share why not okay doctor tournaments
two nights attack actually that was a
one night attack too strong too strong
hey first place staying clean
yeah e4 is bust bite us
don't mess okay playing new player give
me an opening to play yeah what's what's
an opening to play against d4
modern Dutch Dutch okay we're playing a
Dutch because Dutch wow so many people
sing Dutch maybe it's just the same
person with multiple accounts alright so
we'll play the one thing she the thing
about this structure is I could choose
between a stone wall or a Leningrad
Leningrad is like this stone wall is
like this I kind of want to play a stone
wall a stone wall is I'll play c6 looks
weird to play c6 before d5 but opponent
maybe knows kind of what he's doing with
not h3 my h3 is a good move because f4
and d3 ideas oh yeah the stone wall is
playable against earned d4 openings and
I think it's pretty simple to learn it's
just kind of you do this structure and
then there's a bunch of plans revolving
around the structure c5 makes me very
happy
so the the plans involved 94 they also
involve moving the bishop I'll start
with this move
like this is a one kind of bad piece for
black so trying to find it better home
for it I guess on f7 it still looks
passive someday it will flourish wait
don't go now that the game is just
beginning the wall the wall is about to
expand I was gonna say another plan is a
pawn g5 white wants to exploit the
square white might play I for hard to
stop but I'll do my own thing yeah it's
going to be close position so in in
close positions like this I think it's
important identify a few different
things one thing is identify like
possible maneuvers to improve the pieces
so in terms of minor pieces like this is
an idea and this is idea is 64 the other
thing to identify as potential pawn
breaks so I have really just two main
ones between g5 and b6
neither of them seems so appealing but
maybe g5 like if I could play g5 g4 and
then later push the H pawn it could be
something yeah I think I'll start with
g5 well I played that for it to cement
control over a five so if take stakes
there's no more 95 ideas and then the h5
would open for King g7 wreck h8
I wouldn't say f4 is a bad move it's um
I think it's a safe move to try and
clamp down so why it's discouraging this
g4 move I'll play Queenie eights I want
to play Bishop h5
this could be a long grind of some sort
[Music]
medium light what yeah the
text-to-speech
I think read the emoji which was a
thumbs up of the skin tone medium lights
whatever that means
okay
now I'm feeling there's some tension
building my Rick wants to be aligned
with White's King so I'm debating
between this and this
go play King h7 okay white having ideas
of grabbing space not sure if I should
throw in a six nah okay so my thread is
very clear I want to take and then when
g3 I'll see what light does and
sometimes with pawn tension if the
tension remains and you want to build up
with your pieces behind the pawn I think
this is a blunder I think I can just
take opponent miss the threats assuming
I'm not missing anything the pawns
pinned and not defended okay crashing
through still takes work King after I
have Bishop h4 we can take know if I
take first I taking some risk play
Bishop h4
maybe at some point I'll I'll grab the H
pawn I'm also a threatening nice idea to
take in Bishop h5 actually the the real
threat is to take and then take and then
Bishop h5 to win the Queen this is nice
so many streams yeah the days are short
like it gets dark it like for something
p.m. so it's a type of season to stay
inside and stream chess King III give me
three let's take got rid of White's most
powerful piece and whatever white takes
back with I might push up on to open
more lines
hmm calculating d4 takes 48 Queen c4
I also just have Bishop h5 let's play
Bishop h5 simple move no need to
calculate I could take could take the H
pawn I mean putting things on the H file
is kind of the cool thing to do in this
position
d4 also still attractive let's take up
on Knight g1 ok let's play this move Oh
No
let's not play that move actually no
that would be bad
yeah Knight g1 is interesting I should
probably keep the rook lined up with the
King yeah I'm keeping the pin if 92 back
then I can take on a3
debating whether to take with the rook
or the bishop it probably doesn't matter
just take with work and then queen h5
interruptions life will be very good
yeah the pieces the pieces play nice
roll they're harmonizing well how many
pieces can you get on the rim I wasn't
really trying to get as many pieces as
possible
kind of just fell into place this is
still a move d4 Knight takes d4 I've
rook to you for to play rook G for
actually
ruchi for Queen f3 maybe queen g4 I'm
not sure if I have a threat but I'm just
trying to squeeze opponents
take sticks
it's actually kind of hard to break
through yeah this is gonna take more
work than I initially thought
looking at queen g2 here also there's a
problem 94 coming
I could just take her up chief 494
doesn't work though
hmm please each five okay to do
now the king wants to go to f7 so maybe
immediately King f7 looks wrong though
okay I'll just play safe I'll take for a
g6 I'll be up a pawn wait I'm up two
pawns
I'm up two pawns nothing to fear play
Bishop e7 these pawns may be slightly
delicate now I'll push the pawn to h4 if
I get the chance
[Music]
could play a five here rook g-force
still let's play Russia for the idea is
to move here and then start pushing the
pawn the Stonewall yeah Stonewall has
not been broken while also play b5 not
sure how much that does I want to do
this I also have a t4 maybe at the right
moment
there's funny move
oh there's funny move each five each
five funny move oh that's so funny so
why play rook h1 to stop h5 I play h5
anyway if ro takes a tribe rotates g3
and I win a piece if Knight takes h5 I
play Bishop each for obstructing the
rook from defending the knight and
essentially trapping the night I mean
that's move probably is 9 of 6 and then
I just take I went back the pawn and the
fight goes for counter play I block and
I'll still be up to pawns in a more
simplified position and I still have my
Stonewall which is really what matters
the most mean white still has activity
maybe e5 c5
etcetera oh there is check that's kind
of annoying but then g6 check Turkey 7 I
think this is fine I just want to win
Connect four and get a another pass pawn
the Stonewall expanding the Stonewall is
not dead it's just it's going through
some some growth yeah so the calculation
was after it takes takes takes King me
six King afford I'm King up for it on d4
and then yeah life will be pretty good
I play d4 immediately I mean there's
rook here check check and then y'all
start pushing the pond
pawn chain time
I mean white attempting some blockade
yeah the rook wants to come around and
help the pawns advance do I have Connect
four I don't think I have it I have
Connect three that's good enough
[Music]
I just want to toss pawn
yeah whites whites a bit slow with
pushing because the rook is defended by
the pawn so there's no c6 if the rook
moves over I have III which is insta win
exercise sparks welcome back long time
no see how's it going yeah I have 42
seconds okay opponent wants to play c6
it's a reasonable move I'll play this
move just hitting the pawn rook t5
expected okay now probably III yeah just
e3 thread is e2 and then promoting
got upon a stone wall the stone wall has
made it all the way up the board at
least part of the stone wall yeah this
is a fun game
I should like specify if I plays like c4
there are cases where stone wall isn't
as good usually the lines where my plays
like Bishop f4 and develops perhaps more
normally but against g3 lines and stone
walls very playable yeah with with
playing the Dutch there's there's
basically the stone wall Dutch there's a
Leningrad Dutch and then sometimes
there's a classical Dutch anyway thanks
for the opening recommendation to
everyone who recommended the Dutch I
hope you guys enjoyed that oh that was a
tournament chance oh okay
Oh third place let's go all sewn up
juice thanks for the win bits do you
have a timeline for getting GM I have a
command that answers that
do you play other games except chess
yeah I play all their games and quick
Huron answering that I play geoguessr
boggle Scrabble choker recently did a
choker stream which is chess and poker
troughs was a while ago
I've streamed like a good handful of
games on occasion but it's mostly been
chess
okay tell me an opening all berserk pack
show some respect
tell me an opening people as whites can
you play c4 that was the first
suggestion I'm playing in English
English opening time in my transpose
okay c6 so with this move order before I
think is quite strong and then probably
well if I play d4 we transpose into like
some mean line hmm yeah maybe this is
playable for lack I'll play Knight f3
looks interesting I'm inviting d4 if
that happens I'll just maneuver the
night yeah Black has space I have
Knights and let's do yeah I guess all
only berserk if my opponent berserks the
Sudip is pretty easy to play I'll play a
three maybe some idea of some pawn break
and this is kind of interesting I'll
play this first and be flexible
and neither 5-5 hits upon if g6 I'll
consider going in like all the way Wow
let's play this move I'm fantasizing
about Bishop h6 oh that doesn't work
though let's play Knight not h4 doc
wanted to take on that five so I'm
reinforcing the Knights this is a major
idea it might not be that easy to stop
okay black how you're attacking
[Music]
there's a cool variation here I'm not
sure if it works so like taking on g7
the problem is black could take either
night and that line in g3 is a moon
we gonna play g3 so if takes it's a nice
positional transformation hey this is a
key defender for black so I'll be happy
to trade it off now my Knights are not
overlapping I mean I don't have as much
support for that v square and b4 here
let's play before I'll try and work both
sides of the board there would be one
just simple moves it's nice because like
I have pressure here I have ideas of f4
play rook e1
it still takes work now f4 takes this is
a model
I'll see what life does about the the
Knights Knight g4 while some might have
five it's getting a little bit chaotic
we both have pieces in each other's
territory and Mars
Marcel lusts B thanks for subbing
thinking about sacking just Bishop t2
also consider taking on Bishop d2
I'm waiting for the right time till I
take and rookie sudden and have some fun
kill me welcome back Kiyomi was like one
of the first mods for the channel like
two years ago probably 97 97 was 97 I
have to move the nights I could take the
pollen maybe or I could just take the
nights ah I could take them right and
then playoff 3 mmm the night has to go
here in the moment upon or goes here and
I win the pawn ok so I'm down on time
but I'm up a pawn also always play off 3
whenever it's good I want to use a B
file work b6 rook the one coming
[Music]
maybe I'll play a 45 for good measure
maybe I'll still go for ask for choices
choices I'm not sure what this move is
the queenside down to the Bishop a5 is
reasonable
I want to open up my undershirt what to
do
pawns attacked if this move
trying to calculate I have to rely on
intuition times getting low and then
game Queen f3 also Bishop d1 I'll play
vision d1 safe move if work b8 I can
take and take on c5 and then if here I
check him in the bishop
okay bishops pinned this pawns backwards
what to do let's play this move
aggressive throw-in the check first I
think I will throw in the check first
then like f5 soon yeah I want to play
Bishop h5 I'm trying to infiltrate this
pawn is kind of hanging 32 seconds
should be enough time okay I think
opponent plundered opponent was
threatening this and this but I cut off
the defense of this I could take on h6 I
know I know I know I'm thinking takes
let's take here first Queen
how about is Queen Queen here King g2g
to take six Hicks I should find shelter
oh there is that move Chuck okay I win
the Queen this should be convertible
like the car
one legal or a couple legal moves check
and beats okay let's close finish three
seconds to spare I just miss my rook
I forgot the rook was hanging and I
wasn't meeting but I won the Queen
that's what mattered that was a close
one pack two tournaments okay reading on
the rise
second place let's go I guess the don't
[ __ ] that's helped a little bit there
I didn't flag second place playing novel
give me an opening maybe I'll play the
I'll play the ready
remember Kiyomi plays already hopefully
still any ready players in the chats
let's play g3 maybe I'll play like a
King's Indian maybe c4 at some points
oh so many openings being suggested so
true ready it would be like c4 I guess
black is playing at Kings Indian setup
yeah we'll have I'll play in the style
of like pushing the deep on a typical
idea in like English ready positions in
d3 yeah we have we have an English kind
of position now yeah usually if if black
hasn't played h6 it makes sense to play
Bishop g5 I am more than willing to take
and play 95 I give away the bishop era
but I gain time
Queen has to move back to defend and
then I'll play before and it's actually
kind of nice
cuz I'll have I'll have Connect four
very soon or maybe not
well let's play a four nice Queen side
space the pawn chain complements a
bishop wowie for you for interesting
move
I should probably take I should
definitely take I'm wondering after rook
takes if I have any useful discoveries
and there's a few ideas here there's
very thematic idea to play b4
interesting line involving Aram I say b4
idea so play c5 takes and then b5 not
sure if it works if it works sir seems a
little bit unclear maybe just b5
immediately so I don't see any great
knight moves in 95 but then the pawn
hangs as queen g3
now let's play this I'll see where the
night moves
give my opponent a choice chat was
suggesting ID 494 wrote tasty for though
so yeah I have to be careful like if I
do attack the rook I have to see my
opponents follow up Knight has a few
options knight Knight a5 interesting
so this is where c5 actually looks
really attractive I love the work so
realizing like takes I thought I would
have tactics but maybe not
pause attack twice
maybe six of some resource 92 is kind of
safe move I'm trying to find ideas after
like c5 takes e5 I mean I g5 I'm not
seeing anything clear
I mean 92 is maybe the simple approach
to defend the pawn unleash the bishop
the Knights kind of stuck go for a
forest soon taking one look at b6 it's
also interesting be 66 97 now let's play
90 - yeah Queen c2 would run into the
rope takes e4 I mean maybe I had some
better option but this keeps the game
going this doesn't lose anything
trying to look for the questions
favorite Ben & Jerry's tastes I walked
by a Ben & Jerry's in st. Louis other
day I didn't realize they still exist I
forget what the flavors are a maybe
cookie dough something with cookie dough
or the peanut butter cups
wait there's a New York system and the
ready did not know that I don't know if
there's too many openings named for like
American places I feel like most
openings are European Oh Cambridge
Springs yeah that's true
Stafford what's the staff
where is Stafford maybe that's a name I
forget any T recommendations today I
bought I bought some things today from
Whole Foods I show it like a choice this
is what I got today at Whole Foods not
sure if people can see it's a company
called forcing Matic they make basically
mushroom coffee so this is this house
like a lion's mane supplements it's kind
of a tea alternative rookie five okay
let's stay focused I mean I Forza move
F for not sure if F for like helps me or
helps my opponent Queen c2 is natural L
but might hang upon e for playable
I can move back to f3 weaker repeats and
be peaceful thinking like f40 for just
expand also depending where the rook
moves like if turkey Yates
I have b6 now c6 and I fork so rookie a
b6 there's takes but then I take back
oh but then there's Bishop d4
unfortunately it doesn't quite work
whoa work h5 I'm a little bit skeptical
of this move it does have some purpose
but if you like the rooks can be stuck
here
I'm not sure if I can trap it should
probably start with this
I'll the Brooklyn variation of the
Alekhine interesting okay so looks like
I can win material opponent setting up a
trap like take stakes here at there's a
d4 I do have to watch out for I think I
should just take the rook black is gonna
get some comp let's take care first I'm
gonna take care if takes I move back if
takes Sarah I have to move my Knights
not too many options I can't play here
[Music]
have to play Knight before it's a little
bit uncomfortable and black has a lot of
tempo moves okay I think this is a
little bit slow I'm giving up c4 but
then all maybe one c6
ooh my rook my beautiful rook if I play
this there's Bishop b2 hmm I mean I can
get back the exchange and I'll be should
be okay
don't really want to do that but what
else do I do I mean I could play ninety
three lose the pawn well let's see if
flax gonna go for this
oh I forgot about that move I've see
five okay this is gonna be a much bigger
fight
I completely forgot about my Knights
my night was not defended I saw this
static and other lines I could date with
pawn to I'll take with Queen
actually material-wise I mean it's kind
of equal okay this is hanging
but then there's Rick c8 this is not
comfortable it's actually funny line
[Music]
doesn't quite work though it might be
three very strong move in IH fours move
hmm what else to do
there's really not too many options here
thinking rookie one hold tight I'm in
trouble especially black having two
bishops Bishop b4 wow that's another
strong move okay I have I'm just move
just want to trade Queens and try and
like fight back
I have a minute a minute is enough time
for lots of moves f7 is my source of
counterplay the thing is black and trade
Queens anytime but I'm being on the fact
that after it takes takes takes rook c1
I'll get some initiative and time is
ticking
okay I see I see comments in the chat
but I don't want to look at the chat I
have to focus on the game people can
talk to each other in the chats there's
a lot to worry about here
I should f8 o Bishop F fades Wow
okay I'm Bishop I fates are risky move
for black it might just be winning but
this is my counter play to play III
Queen d2 just mating me let's play rook
to you all now I can't play routine one
play work off - I can't believe I got to
either what to play takes on c6
what's wrong with this have to try this
I should have taken on each six probably
in c6 attacked
twenty-eight
okay I recall maybe help out dreaming of
rook to Yates what is this
not enough time oh my gosh
that's a nasty move that's such a nasty
move everything's hanging though well I
mean a plumbing can take anything
Wow
look at that leg the finish was
incredible by black because here it was
still complicated for I'm just wondering
if I had any thought I was feeling
really good here and there Bishop takes
III and this is such a calm idea play 94
I have maybe I should have gone for
Queen no I I don't have any counterplay
in Quincy AIDS Queen da King g7 yeah
kudos
under it okay well engine find anything
what about Knight g4 Knight g4 is what I
played the problem was 94 it's so weird
like everything's hanging and my rooks
pinned and I'm just losing a queen and
then the problem was takes with check so
everything literally everything just
fell if I played this way than this
maybe King e1 was my best try but then
at the very least there's this
there was also probably Queen before man
this computer graph I advantaged slipped
up on the plate very well
was I not I didn't have anything at that
I thought I would have liked I I had a
lot of Hope here with rook T yet ideas
Bishop takes c3 wall yeah I can't be too
upset like the only thing I'm upset
about is missing Queen b6
yeah Bishop that fate was very very
strong okay seven yeah
man computer suggesting lady 492 what to
do
lightning bolts welcome back oh man oh
sorry so the ready fans already was just
torn apart
can i gift a sub tonight powder move on
maybe are they already a sub I'm not
sure doesn't look like moobot saw sub
ready in peace I mean the opening was
completely fine I think we even saw by
the computer graphite was better but
then something went terribly wrong later
who is this person
leba Leba Kongo d welcome to the live
stream desert desert of Rajas Saar I'm
so tilted now do I play a walrus let's
play a let's play a serious walrus this
is usually what I do in like in bullets
but I'll like hi actually I studied this
kind of seriously and I came to the
conclusion that it's playable is it
playable I definitely I remember
studying the slime
I think c5 at some point should be
played maybe right away
okay at least we're getting something
dynamic as fc4 maybe I'll consider b5 I
just want to want to complicate things
I can't complain with this I lost a pawn
but there's some pressure oh that's a
good move
giving me the option of accepting triple
pawns and then efore Saul played before
this is still reasonable
wait love a Congo I say the name Ron how
else do you say it Lubbock on Ola bacán
God or is it Lubbock Kong odd so many
different possibilities okay c6 is kind
of the main break it sucks another pond
that treats Queens in the 94
[Music]
I am intrigued let's do it
threatening to win upon also giving
white a second pot but if white takes
upon eye I take away whites casting
rights and I'll play Bishop a5 probably
at some point I would win back c6 and
hopefully get some comp for whatever
material I'm down bacon bacon
oh there's bacon in that name it's like
bacon Ola bacon God Oh interesting
sometimes I'm blind to bacon just have
to smell for it hey we have another
person
Scola saying hey just found out your
YouTube channel and I'm addicted to
watching the videos even though I don't
know much about chess you make it look
very easy though I don't know oh wait
I've already read that I just had a
question have you ever saw the movie
pawn sacrifice yeah I saw I actually saw
a pawn sacrifice before it was released
to the public there was a private
showing in 20 was a 2017 or 2016
there is a private showing after the
Sinquefield cup and there were at least
like 20 grandmasters watching the movie
and judging the movie was a good movie
though there is a few scenes which were
historically incorrect I want a castle
I'm not sure if I should play rook t8 or
castle let's play castling at some point
I can't access u7 right away but some
point I want to win the pawn in the
meantime whites in check why can either
okay
[Music]
kingi won all I need to do is get the
knight to see - and it's meat or a rook
to d1 or Bishop to see - okay so Bishop
c2 threatens made in one but walks into
92 so I think that makes sense here to
just trade off by one of my worst pieces
for whites only developed piece the idea
is after it takes takes I'll be ready to
double up and mate
I like when Eric drinks to wait drinks
what also I ran out of mushroom coffee
it's a bit more mushroom coffee I would
have to make more hey it's a sub Scola
subbing with twitch Prime
thanks so much Scola as very interesting
thanks for replying love the mug this is
not my mug by the way it's a chest broad
mug it was here when I moved in but it's
a nice mug play this
I mean yeah these are my two one open
file one half open file I'm dreaming of
h3 rook takes c3 pawn decks III bishop
g3 mates it might even make sense to
just sack like take the bishop on e3 and
then 94 because I'm this Bishop would
kind of be dead at least temporarily 92
I'm so tempted to sack I also have this
move Knight Knight g4
I also just have simple plan
I'm Bishop e5 also move target b2 so
many moves at first I was thinking there
should be five castling queenside but
the killer King has already moved i'd
probably win the pawn back but then
maybe lose this pawn it's I think it's
worth it beaches a weak points and in
White's position and there's no rook e1
because I control v1
I'm not sure what lights going to do I
could grab a pawn like there's a line
Bishop takes e5 vision takes B to work
t1 and Bishop c3 who is this pocus lobe
pocus Lube thanks for subbing for two
months
hello hi Eric how has your day been
going it's been going well it's wrapping
up with rapid chess this might be my
last game I was debating whether to play
the full tournament but I stumbled and
it's hard to pick myself up again oh
yeah this is very nice oh this is so so
nice because I'll take in defense I mean
also this move still but yeah this is
very nice construction the pawn defends
a bishop bishop defends the pawn that's
Bishop attacking my things
there's a cool line here okay time to
calculate chats and people watching in
the future on YouTube brace yourself for
arrows rook takes D to king digs D to
rook d8 the White has only a few legal
moves king among its mated bishop here I
just take the bishop
so that means King III only move so it
takes takes takes King III I have Bishop
c1 bishop c1 King f3 it's very very
close to meet I'm not sure if it's me
like I want to play g5 g 5g for there's
also like Bishop g4 King g3 mm-hmm okay
Brooke takes d2 King takes you to King
III it's got to be me somewhere I mean
there's so many different ways to attack
the King kind of also thanks for the sub
chess on earth oh gifting a sub to
Winston Smith ham okay takes takes takes
King III Knight g4 is a move I feel like
there might be just a quiet move
somewhere I mean also just Bishop being
one at any point but I want to mate
okay one last time takes takes takes
because my time is running low
Bishop c1 came out for three bishop pure
King here Knight here came here here g4
I also have a knight of four wait a
minute takes takes takes rook here here
here here here here here
King g4 oh it's so so close f5 King gx8
v g6 my bishop controls this line
there's king h4 g5 let's do it let's do
it it's gonna be fun
put on your seat belts whoa opponent and
do it I was looking forward to so much
fun let's just go for meets opponent was
probably terrified of all the arrows
this is hard to stop now
it is stoppable we'll see what white
does I'll have to go back and analyze
that yeah three good move mmm oh there's
another fun line
I'm in the mood to sack
I'm not seeing actually anything so
clear here let's just check I mean so
many things are winning at this point if
I check oh there is actually fun line
check their promise king f2 goes back I
can play this move
I mean I'm up a full piece but should be
one maybe coming this will be nice this
should be one King Jiwon takes a little
bit of work 54 ideas hey it's another
Sun chess on earth gifting people
sharing the holiday spirits things just
on earth gifting us up tonight creeper
1000 while g4
hmm I want to sack back but I mean take
stakes 94 no way Bishop you one first
let's see what white does a back rank is
being infiltrated just on earth gifting
another sub to James tremble have gifted
5 sub so far thanks so much yeah I'm
watching my time I'm watching the King
closer I'm thinking I'll just sack on g4
I think it makes the most sense because
I'll have I'll have this move there's
actually a funny idea after it takes
here-here Bishop h4 threatening maiden
to
now the bishops will be very strong I'm
not sure if flight can actually stop the
maiden - well maybe I can stop it but
it's not so easy are you coming to
Taiwan anytime soon I was just in Taiwan
are you from Taiwan leba Kongo I was in
Taiwan in October had some really good
tea yeah so this is amazing two bishops
so strong
I could have gotten free rook but I
wanted freakin freakin is nicer ok house
nice house a weird position it was like
a serious fall risk that was a fun game
like the gambit paid off in some respect
I got what I wanted with pawn play and
even though we traded Queens I kept some
tab Michigan 6 was nice why it was just
a little bit slow to develop so maybe
I'll put that on YouTube YouTube people
hope you enjoyed that YouTube people if
you've made it this far
comment below your favorite opening like
what opening do you want to see me play
or do you want me to like teach in a
youtube video and with that I'll see you
in the future